제가 오늘은
요즘에 빌딩 시장에 대해서 좀
설명드리려고 하는데
벌써 이제 1분기가 끝났더라구요 제가
직접 이제 현업에 있으면서 1분기
지금 시장 사항이라든지 요즘에
거래량은 좀 어떤지 한번 좀 영상으로
다뤄보려고 합니다
우선은 올해 1월 달이 아마 제일 안
좋았어요 저도 이어 하면서 거래량이
이렇게 적었던 적은 또 처음이고
1월이나 2월 달에는 거래량이 좀
많이 줄었다가 3월부터는 그래도
계약이 좀 되고 있습니다 저희
중개법인에도
계약이 좀 3월 달에 나왔고 그리고
4월달에는 더 나왔어요
조금 거래량이
늘고 있는 것 같습니다 물론 이제
작년 정도는 아니죠
작년보다 거래량이 좀 줄긴 했지만 1
2열 보다는
그래도 거래량이 좀 상승하고 있다
아마 이제 그렇게 됐던게 1 2월
달에는 이제 연준도 그렇고
금리에 대한
얘기가 대부분 다 이제
매파적인
경향이 되게 셌거든요 근데 이번에
이제
여러 세계 은행이 파산하면서
여러분들도
금리를 이제 좀 안 올릴 것 같다
덜 올릴 것 같다라는 얘기들이 좀
많이
생겨났어요
실제로 그것 때문에 좀 빌딩
문의 주시는 분들이 좀 전보다는 좀
늘어난 것 같습니다 이런 최고가
주택들은 그래도 계속 최고가를
찍으면서 팔리더라구요 최근에 매각됐던
거 중에 하나가 이제 뭐 한남 더
기사를 보면은 110억 올해 최고가
110억의
30대 영국인이 이제 매입했다는
기사인데 이것도 이제 72평짜리인데
110억의 체결이 됐어요 최근에
그리고 이것뿐만 아니라 지금 아마
실거래가 안 나왔지만
기타 되게 유명한 주택들도 최고가를
계속 좀
찍었어요
원밸리 펜트하우스도
기사 갔었죠 100억원에 이제
실거래가 됐고 그리고 빌딩 같은
경우에도 뭐 호가나 이런 거는 조정이
있었어요
호가 보다는
조금 저렴하게 거래가 되긴 했지만
그래도 뭔가 좀 안정적으로 다시 치고
올라가는듯한 느낌이 있는 거 같긴
그리고 오늘 아침에 또 기사인데
은마아파트가
30채 팔렸다는 기사여가지고 저도 좀
찾아봤어요
찾아봤는데 여기 네이버 부동산 보니까
진짜 엄청 많이 팔렸습니다 올해
작년 말이 이제 좀 많이 떨어진
가격에 거래가 됐었고 올해 1월부터
2월 달이 진짜 거래가 많이 되네요
2월달에 하나 둘
셋 넷 다섯 여섯 11개가 됐네요
2월 달에만 그 다음에 3월 달엔
다섯 건 되고 그 지금 가격이 좀 더
올랐죠
괜찮은 아파트 같은 경우에는 계속 좀
이렇게 거래가 되고 있는 거 같습니다
여기뿐만 아니라 잠시 5단지도
잠실 5단지도 계속 거래되고 있어요
보면은 이게 잠시 5단지인데 최근에
또 가격이 좀 올라서
계약이 됐죠 그래서 지금 2023년
2월 달에 18억 7,500이었는데
2023년 3월 달 그러니까 한 달
만에 한 21억에 팔린 것도 있고
24억에 팔린 것도 있어요
그러니까
뭔가 최근에
조금 좀 달라진 것 같습니다 그
어찌됐든 시장 상황이 좀 많이 안
좋긴 해서
돈을 계속 좀 더
찍어낼 것 같아요 그리고
연주 내에서도
속도도 좀 조절하고
원래는 이제 뭐 6% 뭐 그 이상
올린다고까지 얘기했는데 최근에는 이제
5%대 초반
얘기를 하더라구요 그리고 지금
빌딩 담보로 대출을 받으면
작년 말만 해도 한 7%가 나왔어요
담보대출 금리가 7%인데
요즘에 나가는 건 5%대 나가더라구요
그리고 저희가 제일 좀 저렴하게
받았던 건 한 4%대
정도 나가고 지금
금리도 전보다는 좀 떨어진 것
같습니다 그리고 사람들이 이제 또
적응하기 시작했어요이 금액에
그러면서
조금 거래량이 느는게 아닌가 이렇게
예상을 하고 그리고 아마 제가 그
작년에 찍었던
영상이 있을 거예요
작년에 찍었던 영상에서 제가 올해
상반기가 매우 안 좋을 거라고 제가
언급을 했었는데
매우 지금 안 좋은 상황이긴 하지만
상황이 좀 되게 급변했어요 3월부터
3월부터 이제 좀 생각보다
그래도 빨리 안정기를 찾을 것 같긴
합니다 제 느낌상 봤을 때
근데 뭐 제가 전에도 말씀드렸지만
어찌됐든
초저금리 때
시대에 투자했던 방법이랑은 조금 다른
방법으로 접근하셔야 되고
확실한 빌딩만 투자를 해야 되고 지금
같은 시기는 되게 좀 옥석을 가리는
식인 것 같습니다 오르는 덴 오르고
빠지는데 빠지고 이런 식으로 더 갈
거 같아요 그래서 저는 지금 현금을
가지고 계신 분들은 지금이
투자하기에는 되게 좀 좋은 시기라고
생각을 합니다 지금 같은 시기에는
대출을 많이 받으면 안 돼요 왜냐면
금리가 높기 때문에
그러니까
풀 레버리지를 이용해서 하는 투자는
안 되고 어느 정도 현금이 확보된
상태에서
투자하는 걸 좀 권해드리고 무조건
주요 지역에 사야 됩니다
한 100번도 넘게 얘기한 거 같아요
영상 찍으면서 2분기 하반기도 좀
예상 해보자면 2분기도
작년보단 거래가 좀 줄긴 하겠지만
1분기보다 거래량이 좀 더 나올 것
같긴 해요 그리고 하반기는
조금 지켜봐야 될 것 같긴 하지만
지금 같이 뭐
금리를 여기서 더 이상 올리지
않는다는 가정하에는
상반기보다는 거래량이 좀 더 늘 거
같습니다
시안함이라고 하기는 모르지만 최고가
찍는 건 계속 최고가 찍고 안
팔리는데 계속 안 팔리고 뭔가 이런
시장이 될 거 같아요
지역별로
격차가 되게 심해질 것 같습니다 더
일단은 제 개인적인 결론은 더 저는
최악일 거라고 생각을 했지만 작년
말에 안정화되는 시기가 생각보다 좀
빨리 온 거 같아요 그래서 지금
대출금리도 많이 내려갔고 그리고 돈을
더 찍어내려는 움직임도 좀 있어서
생각보다 그런 안정화 시기가 좀 빨리
온 상태고 그래서 만약에 지금 빌딩
투자를 계획하고 계신다라고 하면
조금 빨리
매입하는 것도 한번 좀 고려해보고
그리고 지금 최근에 또 저희가
자산운용사분들도 좀 만나면 올해
매입하려는 운영사들도 꽤 있는 거
같아요 1분기
빌딩 통계 가지고 좀 말씀을 드렸는데
어찌됐든 일리얼이 좀 최악이었고
3월부터 분위기가 좀 반전됐다 이렇게
좀 정리를 해 볼 수 있을 것 같고
그리고 2분기는
작년보단 거래량이 줄긴 하겠지만
1분기 보다는 거래량이 더 늘 거
같고
하반기도
상반기보다는 더 좀 거래량이 늘 거
같습니다 지금 같은
금리가 유진된다는 가정하에 지금 같은
시기에는 확실한 것만 좀 투자하시길
좀 바라고 제발 부탁드립니다 저희
구독자 여러분들은 좀 잘 사셨으면
좋겠어요 잘 샀다고 저한테 뭔가
댓글도 남겨주시고 뭐 메일도
보내주시고 하면 저는 그게 너무
뿌듯합니다 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다